from the beginning you're going to feel
the pain of the father taking his kids
who is approached by a recruiter saying
your kids can be models they can be in
movies father dresses in a suit takes
them to this room and he takes the kids
there they're excited put the kids in
the room and the girl says come back to
pick him up at seven o'clock he said
what do you mean come back to pick him
up at seven o'clock he leaves comes back
seven o'clock no one's there shut down
that's how the movie starts it's
disturbing it's emotional it's tough
it's painful at the end Jim Caviezel
gives a message when the movie ends
three minutes later he's given a message
profound message that you have to watch
the stats that they gave that uh 20 plus
million child pornography pictures were
uploaded on the internet the last year a
five thousand percent increase in the
last five years